bonjour à tous il y a
très longtemps pas dans une galaxie
lointaine mais en tout cas à paris mais
un jeune garçon c'était moi je n'aimais
pas l'école je la comprenais pas elle ne
me comprenait pas j'étais un de ces
garçons que vous connaissez ou fille qui
est dans le fond de la classe à côté du
radiateur et qui avertissements de
travail avertissements de conduite
chaque année s'était enfermé chance de
rentrer à lille ça était d'au moins 1000
%
deux choses ont régi ma vie pendant ce
long parcours jusqu'au bac
c'étaient les livres en être le héros où
j'adorais me les lire et j'ai terminé la
collection il ya quelques mois
pourquoi parce que j'avais l'impression
d'être quelqu'un d'important j'incarnais
un héros et les contes de fées que je
retrouvais par le biais du cinéma ou par
le biais de la littérature et ça me
créer des univers énorme et je pensais
que justement vivantes ces deux là
j'allais m'en sortir
une des histoires qui m'a le plus marqué
il ya très longtemps c'était l'histoire
du petit tailleur vous la connaissez
sûrement c'est ce fameux petit canal
tailleur qui vit d'habitude tous les
jours il fait exactement la même chose
il re coût des vêtements et un jour il
décide de juges changer une de ses
habitudes c'est à dire que au lieu de
manger du pain rassis ce avec rien
dessus décide de dépenser un peu
d'argent pour s'acheter un petit pot de
confiture il recouvre de confiture sa
tartine et le temps qu'il se retourne
pour poser son couteau il y à déjà cette
mouche sur sa tartine alors excédé il
prend un torchon
il tape ça tartini lantus est d'un coup
il s'écrie j'en ai tué celle d'un coup
et à ce moment là ils disent à son
voisin qui va le répéter à quelqu'un
d'autre et le répéter le répéter jusqu'à
ce que la rumeur face qu'on lui dise il
a tué sept brigands d'un coup et à ce
moment là on vient le chercher et il se
rend au château où il va avoir plusieurs
défis qui va relever et à la fin il
terminera roi ça m'avait marqué je me
suis dit waouh je mets professeur voilà
ce que pensent mes professeurs de moi et
il pense que je n'arriverai à rien alors
je me suis dit que comme ce petit
tailleur est une question clé c'est
quand est ce que pour la dernière fois
j'ai fait quelque chose pour la première
fois
cette question en est elle à changer la
vie du petit tailleur puisque pour la
première fois ils mettaient de la
confiture je me suis dit que ça a changé
sa vie si je faisais quelque chose pour
la première fois ça l'est peut-être
changé ma vie parce que faire quelque
chose pour la première fois c'est pas
grand chose c'est d'aller tester une
nouvelle cuisine dans un nouveau
restaurant s'est appelé un ami et
refaire un projet qu'on a laissé dans un
tiroir c'est faire une petite chose
nouvelle comme un comme change comme
quand on était jeunes dont on a enlevé
les roues arrière de notre vélo
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a appris
l'equilibre faire une nouvelle chose
c'est seul gré des c'est d'être bien
meilleur c'est de s'améliorer c'est
d'apprendre quelque chose de nouveau
et voici derrière moi ce que les
professeurs penser de moi à l'époque
trop effacé en classe un comportement
peu enclin au travail élèves difficiles
à cerner peu concernés par la formation
pas de travail des absences élèves
beaucoup trop sûr de lui dont le niveau
s'est dégradée tout au long de l'année
et qui la plus tordue temps s'amuse à
dissiper la classe
alors les chances du bac j'ai réussi à
avoir le meilleur score au pourcentage
était à 1 % seul un prof de maths a dit
bon bah on va lui donner la probabilité
donc j'avais un pour cent de chances de
réussir au bac
qu'est ce que j'ai fait je me suis
plongé dans milite sans être le héros
que je continue à lire et dans ce conte
du petit tailleur et je me suis fait
peut-être changer quelque chose on
arrive au bac de français et je me
retrouve avec cette liste que je n'ai
jamais eu de 40 texte à proposer on est
mal j'arrive devant l'examinatrice un
copain m'avait filé la liste de dernier
avec les photocopies qu'il fallait des
textes il les avait en triple et donc du
coup j'arrive à cet ex examina fils elle
choisit clair de lune de victor hugo et
à ce moment là j'ai dix minutes pour me
préparer pendant qu'un autre passe
devant l'examinatrice dix minutes je me
suis je suis fan de l'année en séance
d'eddy mitchell j'aime le cinéma les
livrets que le héros je vais essayer de
prendre cette scène du clair de lune de
victor hugo
comme une pièce de théâtre où comme à
une scène de cinéma et je me retrouve
face à elle je lui raconte qu' un
réalisateur qui a des figurants qui a
des premiers rôles tous âges invente
tout un univers autour de ça voici la
note que j'ai eu à l'oral alors
alors les cris c'était pas ça on peut
pas tricher mais voilà la personne ne me
connaissait pas et je pense que d'avoir
changé cette manière de penser à fait
que j'ai eu cette note ça m'a donné
énormément de confiance en moi et à ce
moment là je me suis dit que je pouvais
avoir mon bac comme ce petit tailleur
pouvait être roi et c'est ce qui s'est
passé et de fil en aiguille je me suis
dit j'avais vu dumbo j'ai découvert
dumbo juste après cette période du bac
ou en fait d'un beau essaye de volée et
on lui donne une plume et avec cette
plume il vole et abandonné il perd cette
plume il se retrouve en plein danger on
lui dit que la plume n'était juste un
objet qui servait à rien et c'était pour
lui faire prendre confiance en lui et à
ce moment là je me suis dit mais je suis
sûr que je pourrais trouver un objet qui
va m'accompagner toute ma vie cet objet
vous l'avez vous aussi ce objet c'est
une simple clé analysons celles créées
prenons par exemple que quand il ya un
pic vers le haut c'est quand un
événement bon vous arrive vous dit c'est
génial tout va bien je suis dans la
période haute et quand quelque chose ne
va pas bien on prend le creux et quand
quelque chose est stable que c'est la
routine on va dire que c'est la petite
barre stable et quand ça descend sur le
fond c'est en fin de vie ça c'est plutôt
les filles parce que justement en fin de
vie rien ne va plus le corps change tout
change et donc ça m'a rappelé un compte
le conte c'était celui du vieux sage
elle est prêt et personne ne le connaît
vraiment bien ce qu'ont ces dix ans de
ce sage qui est dans une cabane avec son
fils en haut d'une colline le village
est en bas et un jean à cheval vient lui
rendre visite
et là les gens du village s'écrit assez
génial vous avez un étalon vous allez
pouvoir labour et votre champ et lui dit
on verra il commence à construire une
clôture avec le bois qu'il avait gardé
pour l'hiver pour se chauffer et à ce
moment là une fois la clôture terminé le
cheval prend son élan saute la clôture
et s'en va et la légende ugdd agissent
armés c'est terrible vous avez construit
la clôture il a plus le bois est mouillé
vous n'avez plus rien pour l'hiver est
là le vieux sage dit on verra
une semaine après le cheval revient avec
une jument est un poulain là les gens
disent mais c'est fabuleux vous avez
maintenant trois chevaux voudrait
pouvoir labourer le champ et faire plein
d'autres choses avec hélas le vieux sage
dit qu on verra à ce moment-là son fils
essaye de monter sur les talons et là
les talons prend un peu peur il ce câble
fiston il se brise les vertèbres
marchera plus jamais les gens du village
disent c'est terrible ce qui vous arrive
est horrible hélas le sachent dit à ce
moment-là il a guerre éclate les hommes
sont envoyés au front l'enfant lui ne
peut pas partir parce que ils allaient
bref vertèbres les femmes 17 et ri vous
vous avez pas pouvoir on va gagner cette
guerre malheureusement la guerre est
perdue tous les hommes sont tués
et là les gens disent c'est terrible
votre fils a échappé à la guerre
s'il n'y avait pas eu cheval en soirée
est sortie et là le vieux sage dit cette
fameuse phrase on verra voilà comment le
vieux sages considèrent la vie comme une
clé inversé c'est à dire qu'il ne pomme
pose aucun pour lui les événements ne
sont ni bons ni mauvais combien de fois
avez vous entendu de votre vie c'est un
bien pour un mal
ou c'est un mal pour un bien voilà on
met nos sentiments par rapport aux
événements qui nous qui se posent en
face de nous et on dit c'est bon ou
c'est mauvais mais ce n'est pas du tout
le cas il faut prendre ça comme quelque
chose de neutre et de voir sur le très
très long terme et de là je me suis
rendu compte d'un personnage que
j'aimais bien quand j'étais petit c'est
mon conte préféré c'est le petit poucet
on le considérait comme quelqu'un de pas
adapté dans son coin
les frères disent c'est un échec et un
jour la disette touche la famille dont
les parents sont obligés de se séparer
des enfants de les perdre dans la forêt
pour que des seigneurs puisse les
recueillir
afin de les nourrir alors la première
fois le petit poucet prend des petits
cailloux vous connaissez l'histoire il
sème le sol de cailloux pour retrouver
la trace de sa maison il revient avec
ses frères ses frères sont heureux et
tout se passe bien la famille est
contente mais la famille contre la
famine continue et la disette et durera
sont là les parents reconduit ses
enfants d'un forêt mais cette fois ils
enlèvent les pierres que le petit poucet
avait dans ses poches mais lui avait été
un peu malins ils s'étaient adaptés la
première situation il avait pris les
morceaux de pain il avait parsemé le
chemin de pain mais malheureusement les
oiseaux ont picoré ce pain donc ils se
retrouvent sans chemin retour et là ses
frères lui dise c'est un échec on va
mourir mangés par les loups qu'est ce
qu'on va faire et là le petit poucet
s'adapte à la situation comme le vieux
sage il dit on verra on va continuer et
vous connaissez la fin de l'histoire il
rentre dans un chai un ogre
il repart et les bottes de sept lieues
il devient riche puisqu'ils ramènent la
cadre une cagnotte de l'ogre à ce moment
là je me suis dit un simple petit poucet
a pu changer une chose juste en ayant
confiance en lui en s'adaptant la
situation un autre l'a fait parce qu'il
la considérait l'échec comme quelque
chose de très différent
j'ai raté
mille tir dans ma carrière j'ai presque
perdu 300 matches 26 mai fois on m'a
fait confiance pour prendre le tir de la
victoire et j'ai raté j'ai échoué encore
et encore et encore dans ma vie et c'est
pourquoi je réussis à votre avis michael
jordan
alors j'ai fait une petite faute
d'orthographe express porras vous
suiviez c'est avec un cas mais en fait
michael jordan à l'époque voulait être
joueur professionnel de baseball il
s'est fait virer et les est venu
professionnelle de basket et c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est que l'échec
pour ces gens là n'existe pas philip
k.dick dit si la réalité c'est ce qui
vous restera si vous cessé d'y croire la
réalité si vous abandonnez c'est ce qui
vous restera par contre si vous
continuer à y croire
vous continuez à écrire l'histoire c'est
ce qu'on fait beaucoup de gens vous
allez le voir parce que il faut savoir
une chose la nasa par exemple vous dira
que échoué n'est pas une option pour eux
échoué c'est dramatique non pour moi
échoué doit être une option
vous devez échouer pour vous améliorer
vous devez considérer les tchèques comme
une option
par contre ce que vous devez sortir de
votre vie c'est de vous dire que la peur
est une option non la peur n'en est pas
une
la peur est un choix il y a deux types
de peur la première celle d'un événement
qui va vous arriver une voiture qui font
ça c'est une vraie peur et puis à
l'autre peur les films je n'ose pas
faire ça parce qu'il va mais arrivé ça
je n'ose pas draguer la fille au premier
rang parce qu'elle me dire ah non je
n'ose pas faire un thé dicks parce que
je vais est ridicule sur scène ça c'est
vous leur est le meilleur réalisateur de
ses propres peurs parce qu'elle n'existe
pas elle existe que dans vos têtes
regardez je vous montrais des gens qui
n'ont pas eu l'échec en tête
steven spielberg il lui a fallu il a été
recalé trois fois ses études de cinéma
auquel n'a pas fait d'études de cinéma
il est rentré chez universal par la
petite porte et il a fait son métier
il a fallu à harry potter 8 d'une maison
d'édition lui refus pour pouvoir enfin
exister avec un tout petit éditeur c'est
pas des gros chiffres là on va le monter
d'un cran
walt disney 300 une banque 300 un refus
pour proposer son parc à thème on va
plus loin
1161 refus de restaurants pour acheter
la recette secrète du colonel juste
penser à ça 1161 refus vous
dans une vie à quel moment sur un projet
vous allez vous arrêter sans refus
d'hier fut qu'un refus 200 refus ce mec
là le colonel a fait du nord au sud de
l'est à l'ouest des états unis pour
proposer cette recette il a fait tous
les états unis pendant une période de 10
ans et vous savez qu'il colonel c'est
celui qui a monté kfc quand vous allez
chez kfc dites-vous qu'il a été refusé
mille cent soixante et une fois et vous
tous dans cette salle mais moi y compris
on a touché chou et plus de 2000 fois
sans nous en rendre compte parce qu'on
n'avait pas la connaissance de ce mot
échec parce qu'il faut à peu près 2000
tentative à un enfant pour marcher et
pourtant ça nous a pas gênés
je me suis demandé d'où venait le mot
échec et je me suis rendu compte que le
mot échec vient de mon entourage de ma
famille de mes amis et parfois même de
mes collègues qui me disent tu vas pas y
arriver ne le fais pas ça c'est ce qu'on
a c'est le bruit du monde ce sont les
mangeurs de rêve garder ce qui a pour
vous à l'intérieur de vous comme une
valeur sûre comme une réalité
continuez et vous allez voir que les
gens vont essayer de pervertir les
choses comme ce compte vous connaissez
tous le petit chaperon rouge qui connaît
vraiment la fin du chaperon rouge
certains d'entre vous me dire on le
chaperon rouge au final il se fait et il
se fait aider par le bûcheron qui arrive
un autre là dira oh non non non c'est le
chasseur qui rentre dans la cabane et
qui tue nos dire on n'en sait la
grand-mère qui sort du placard ouvre le
ventre du loup sort le petit chaperon
rouge remplace par des pierre et le loup
se se fait tuer faut la vraie fin c'est
que le petit chaperon rouge ça fait
manger pourtant nous avons toutes ses
fins différentes ces apn parce que la
censure de l'époque l'exigé et surtout
que nos parents nous ont retransmis ce
message et nous leur transmettrons à nos
enfants
donc quand on parle de l'échec d'un
échec mais on vous dit ça on le garde
quand quelqu'un vous dit vous n'allez
pas y arriver si vous prenez ça comme
content c'est ce qui sera votre réalité
et je vous montrais deux exemples
il n'y a pas très longtemps chez les
manger chez une amie et elle prend le
jambon et le couple est coin de ce
jambon et j mais pourquoi tu fais ça
est ce que c'est parce que tu l'as pris
avec les doigts et du coup tu préfère
couper les angles ne sachant plus quelle
langue tu as touché
ou est ce que c'est parce qu'il ya du
gras sur la périphérie elle me dit non
je ne sais pas mais ma mère me disait de
faire ça et elle l'a toujours fait je
demande si on peut appeler sa mère
on appelle sa mère et à ce moment elle
me dit bas
on faisait ça dans la famille ma mère le
faisait voilà alors là du coup j pourvu
que la grand-mère soit en vie on appelle
la grand mère la grand-mère est en vie
et je me dis pourvu qu'elle me dise pas
que c'est l'arrière grand mère
sinon ça va aller loin et elle me dit
non non je faisais ça parce que le
jambon rentrait pas dans mon plat
faisons un test
qu'est ce qui se passe quand vous voyez
une étoile filante dans le ciel vous
faites tous la même chose vous faites un
voeu je suis allé à l'origine de cette
histoire ça remonte à la grèce antique
ou en fait la vraie chose qu'il faut
faire c'est qu'il faut faire un voeu
dans la journée et quand vous voyez une
étoile filante le veut pas se réaliser
ce qui veut dire que quand vous voyez
une étoile filante dans le ciel c'est le
voeu de quelqu'un d'autre qui se réalise
le monde change et le conseil reste et
c'est ce conseil qu'il faut éviter parce
que il est toujours là mais il ya un
conseil que j'ai apprécié dans ma vie
c'est cet arbre de vie égyptien ils
datent de trois mille ans il y a cinq
oiseaux le premier la naissance
l'enfance l'adolescence l'âge adulte et
la vieillesse le premier oiseau vous le
voyez il est sur la branche la plus
basse il n'attend rien de la vie
l'enfant lui d'un coup soit une fille
elle veut devenir vétérinaire un enfant
un garçon pilote d'avion lui attend
quelque chose de la vie ils voient
beaucoup de potentiel et de futurs
possibles
donc on est sur la branche un peu plus
haute l'adolescent lui maintenant et sur
la branche la plus haute pourquoi parce
qu'il croit que tout est possible et qui
croit qu'il va réussir mais le monde
extérieur les touffes le conseilleur
d'orientation pourrait peiner sait tous
elle voulait tout dire non c'est pas
possible vos mieux être coiffeur moi
elle me disait travaille dans un
restaurant et donc du coup c'est monde
extérieur vous étouffe et à ce moment-là
l'âge adulte on descend d'une branche et
l'adulte ouvre ses ailes parce qu'il
décide de s'envoler décide de faire
quelque chose mais si c'était le cas il
n'y aurait aucun oiseau sur la dernière
branche parce qu'il se serait envolé
pourquoi il ya un oiseau sur la dernière
branche tout simplement parce qu'il a
décidé de s'en vanter
mais il n'a pas agi il est resté sur
cette branche tous les oiseaux regarde
vers le futur
sauf celui de la vieillesse qui regarde
vers le passé
c'est ça qui est terrible ne pas croire
en ses rêves ne pas les défendre
ne pas s'y accrocher c'est ce qui fait
que ça n'existe plus et abandonner les
regrets reste j'ai beaucoup croisé de
gens qui disent
j'ai réussi à faire ça et toutes les
fois où il échoue à j'ai échoué à cause
des autres j'ai échoué parce qu'il y
avait ça et se trouvent des excuses mais
au final la vraie réalité ce n'est pas
ça je me suis rendu compte que ceux qui
réussissaient ne réussissait avec les
autres aient échoué par eux mêmes parce
qu'à un moment donné il décidé
d'abandonner
et cette phrase me restait beaucoup et
elle me faisait penser à un conte qui
s'appelle le chat botté un meunier vient
de mourir il lègue à ses trois fils des
biens le premier gagne une maison le
deuxième gagne le bétail le troisième
juste un chat il décide de manger le
seul chat dit attentes autant faisons
équipe travaille on sent peut-être qu'on
arrivera à quelque chose
donnons nous la main et qu'est ce qui se
passe à la fin il vient roi le chat
botté
c'est vous c'est votre copain de classe
c n'importe qui qui est à côté de vous
moi par exemple je suis ici tout
simplement parce que patrick boos un
jour m'a dit ça te dirait de faire ça et
florian et son équipe m'ont aidé à venir
sur scène et je trouve que ce sont mes
chapeauté du moment il y en a partout
autour de vous il sont éphémères ils
sont là il suffit juste de les
reconnaître et ces gens là ce sont des
gens bienveillants des gens qui vont
vous écoutez elle est dans le sens de
votre projet par contre fuyez les
voleurs de rêve
fuyez les vous allez le reconnaît c'est
toujours ceux qui vont vous dire c'est
pas possible tu n'y arriveras pas parce
que dans leur monde et dans leur réalité
à eux c'est impossible mais pas dans la
vôtre continuer à avancer sur ça soyez
le where il ya un film que j'aime
beaucoup qui montre ce que l'histoire du
petit tailleur c'est pour moi l'histoire
moderne du petit tailleur voulait
peut-être sûrement vu c'est l'histoire
d'un mec qui vit tous les jours le même
jour mais c'est marrant parce qu'on
parle que de ce jour là on ne parle pas
des jours avant que ce ne serait pas
intéressant à filmer il faut savoir que
ce mec là tous les jours de sa vie vit
la même routine
sauf qu'à un moment donné il vit le même
jour mais avant ils avaient la même
routine mais en vivant ce même jour il
décide quoi de se suicider parce qu'il
se rend compte d'une chose c'est que sa
vie n'est qu'une suite de routine et que
le temps passe vite et que ça ne
l'intéresse pas et pourtant à un moment
donné il change d'état d'esprit sa
manière de penser changer décide d'être
meilleur d'apprendre à faire du piano de
faire de la sculpture sur glace d'aidé
dans une association des sdf et commence
à rencontrer des gens qui l'apprécient
et lui apprécié enfin les gens et qu'est
ce qui se passe à la fin il rencontre
l'amour de sa vie et tous ces projets se
changent et c'est ça que je trouve
important c'est justement de pouvoir
changer ça et vous pouvez le faire il
suffit juste
de faire un pas de prendre une nouvelle
décision comme lui car cette question
qui est quant à lui vous fait quelque
chose pour la première fois c'est
extrêmement important
j'essaie de faire une chose tous les
jours vous verrez que faire une chose
tous les jours ça devient un automatisme
exemple aujourd'hui je fais ma première
fois avec vous c'est mon premier tedx de
toute ma vie et faisait partie d'une
liste de 100 une chose que je voulais
faire dans ma vie et comment ça s'est
fait j'en ai pas parlé naturellement ça
nous la trique en parler et voilà et
j'en aurai jamais parlé une première
fois
merci et meresse cinq secondes cinq
secondes pour vous dire que ma première
fois demain matin je vais aller voir le
spectacle de guignol dans le vieux lyon
parce que ça sera ma première fois merci
à vous